[Musik]
vor genau 500 jahren hat dieser mann
hier martin luther gegen den
ablasshandel die kirche und den papst
gewettert sein gewissen wollte es so
welches erbe hat er damit in unserer
kultur und unseren köpfen hinterlassen
darüber darf ich mit zwei wichtigen
frauen des diesjährigen
reformationsjubiläums sprechen
margot käßmann ist evangelisch
lutherische theologin und pfarrerin und
aktuell botschafterin der lutherdekade
christina aus der au ist philosophin und
evangelisch reformierte theologin und
präsidierte den deutschen evangelischen
kirchentag in diesem jubiläumsjahr
herzlich willkommen in beiden dann sehr
gerne vor 500 jahren im jahr 517 am 31
oktober hat martin luther seine 95
thesen gegen den ablasshandel an die
schlosskirche in wittenberg gehängt und
hat so einiges ausgelöst damit zum
beispiel auch dass wir heute all diese
schönen artikel haben eine mütze noch
gar nicht gesehen
mick box mit der aufschrift hier ein
stent hier stehe ich dann so eine
badeente natürlich diese berühmte und
bestverkaufte playmobil figur und dieses
land rot war was würde ihnen martin
luther eigentlich von diesem marketing
maßnahmen halten
also ich denke er würde lachen weil er
hat gesagt das evangelium kann nur mit
humor gepredigt werden also luther hatte
schon humor darüber das ist nicht von
der kirche erfunden aber ich glaube es
gibt heute keine großveranstaltung ohne
merchandising mehr sie können auch nach
rom fahren oder konnte den papst als
hängt der tasse sehen oder als spardose
insofern ich glaube das gehört heute
dazu es hätte ihm auch gefallen sein
konterfei darüber nicht ganz uneitel und
schon im dienste der botschaft des
evangeliums zurück ich glaube er hätte
auch ein vergnügen gehabt
mein favorit ist ja dass hier luden was
martin luther heute verordnen würde mit
4 fach wird vom form darüber werden wir
sprechen das sind sprüche verstimmt da
für geist und seele und vor der sendung
oder am anfang der
darf ich sie bitten als zu nehmen und
das dort zu lesen
die müsste der glückskeks bitteschön
christina eine lüge ist wie ein
schneeball je länger man ihm selbst
desto größer wird er weiß halt oder das
ist eine weisheit finde das ist jetzt
wirklich alle weisheit dass von mutter
ist hätte ich nicht gewusst das
evangelium ist wie ein frisches sanftes
kühles lüftchen in der großen hitze des
sommers wenn sie das hin ist kette
darauf habe ich auch schon gehört hätte
ich auch nicht gleich links nicht so
ordneten aber selbst die experten leider
noch ist keine lutter experte
ich hätte da auch gesagt das ist
jedenfalls überraschen ich hätte er
gesagt an das evangelium ist wie ein
sturm oder ein frischer wind aber nicht
ein lichtlein sondern etwas als durch
place wir versuchen jetzt in der ersten
haben schon ein bisschen diesen dieser
figur luther näher kennenzulernen bevor
wir das machen sollten wir unser
gedächtnis ein bisschen auffrischen mit
einem humorvollen animationsfilmen
witziger film und was ganz wichtig ist
kommt darf ich mich zur sprache nämlich
das gewissen luther seine thesen
widerrufen
15.21 in worms und dann hat er folgendes
gesagt er hat gesagt wenn ich nicht mit
den zeugnissen der schrift oder mit
offenbaren vernunftgründen besiegt werde
so bleibe ich von den schriftstellern
besiegt die ich an geführt habe und mein
gewissen bleibt gefangen in gottes wort
widerrufen kann und will ich nichts weil
es weder sicher noch geraten ist etwas
gegen sein gewissen zu tun als er beruft
sich auf die bibel auf die vernunft aber
vor auf das gewissen und sie vergessen
meint das sei ein meilenstein gewesen
ja ich denke das ist ein meilenstein
weil das individuelle gewissen jetzt
entsteht nicht der papst nicht der
kaiser nicht der fürst sagen dem was du
zu glauben hast sondern du sollst selbst
dein gewissen schärfen an der bibel
meinte natürlich und an der vernunft und
dann kannst du selbstständig
entscheidungen treffen das ist natürlich
ein riesiger schritt hin zu
individuellen ja überzeugungen dann auch
eines tages zu individueller
meinungsfreiheit rede freiheit
menschenrechten das konnte er damals
noch nicht sehen luther und ich muss ja
auch sagen er hat das für sich selbst
eingefordert hat aber nicht toleriert
wenn andere andere entscheidung
getroffen haben aber der gedanke war in
der welt dass jeder mensch ein eigenes
freies gewissen hat und das ein enormer
schritt richtung neuzeit raus aus dem
mittelalter sehen sie das ähnlich
ja ja ja ja und nein also luther hätte
mit allgemeinen menschenrechten und mit
der aufklärung auch schon so sein dass
hier nicht das gewissen das erste also
nicht vor allem das gewissen sondern vor
allem die bindung an gott vor allem die
bibel und das gewissen in an gottes wort
und in gottes wort gefangen und deswegen
wird der film so wird sicher ist aber
die die szene war auf dem klo sitzt und
grübelt da ist nicht das klo das
wichtige sondern die bibel die vor ihm
auf der auf dem boden liegt und er hat
das nicht mit grübel herausgefunden also
nicht in seinem eigenen herz erforscht
sondern in den biblischen texten im
römerbrief gelesen und ich glaube dass
dieser individualismus denen ich ja auch
extrem wichtig finde und demokratie und
menschenrechten religionsfreiheit und
alles aber für lothar war
das grundlegende dass wir nur in gott
und an gold gebunden frei sind und unser
gewissen auch nur so frei sein kann es
ist nicht der mensch selber es ist der
christ mensch und er dadurch gesagt
jeder soll die bibel lesen können um das
eigene gewissen an der bibel zu schärfen
deshalb hat er die bibel in die deutsche
sprache übersetzt
deshalb hat er dann auch die fürsten
aufgefordert schulen zu gründen für
jeden jungen und damals auch schon jedes
mädchen das war revolutionär denke ich
damit sie die bibel selber lesen können
und dann an der bibel ihr gewissen
schärfen aber schon ihr eigenes gewissen
weil sie sich nicht mehr vom priester
von pfarrer sagen lassen wie sie zu
verstehen haben sondern dass selbst
jeder trainer verantwortlich aber was
wissen dass dieses gewissen was ist das
natürlich eine gute frage ich denke dass
er sagen würde an der bibel findest du
heraus welche haltung du im leben ein
einzunehmen hast und was in deinem leben
die richtigen entscheidungen sind und
wenn du dein gewissen an der bibel
geschafft hast dann kannst du auch
entscheidungen treffen und eine haltung
im leben einnehmen er sagt ja das leben
im kloster ist nicht das bessere leben
das sieht ja gar nicht ein warum du dich
zurückziehen sollte ist aus der welt
sondern da mitten in der welt wo du
deine familie hast das auch eine
aufwertung von sexualität kindern
familien leben da wo du deinen beruf
hast als handwerker als fürst aber auch
als besen schwingen dem markt da hast du
verantwortung in der welt zu übernehmen
und im grunde ist das eine aufwertung
von weltlichem leben weil du jetzt in
der welt vor gott verantwortlich leben
kannst und nicht vor gott nur
verantwortlich lebst wenn du dich ganz
zurückzieht aus der bösen sündhaften
welt was ist wenn wir an meinem gewissen
sagt ich soll die bibel links liegen
lassen
das konnte sich nicht vorstellen denke
ich also auch die vernunft werde dass
also da hat ja zur vernünftiges
verhältnis olivenernte das auch nicht
sagen etwas links liegen zu lassen wenn
dann damit auseinandersetzen also sich
einlassen auf etwas mit dem ganzen mit
dem ganzen geist seele verstand kopf mit
allem als ganze person dahinter und
nicht einfach ausblenden ist aber wenn
ich jetzt die bibel lese und dann auch
zum schluss kommen das ist nichts für
mich ich sehe da keine guten argumente
dringen ich glaube nicht an gott mit
meinem gewissen stimmt das nicht überein
was er da luta gesorgt
nun denke ich wir leben heute in einer
zunehmend säkularisierten welt in der
schweiz aber natürlich auch in
deutschland und ganz besonders in
ostdeutschland wo die reformation
stattgefunden hat aber das konnte sich
luther eigentlich nicht vorstellen eine
säkularisierte welt oder eine welt in
der menschen völlig ohne glauben leben
das war in der mitte mittelalterlichen
welt gar nicht denkbar da war einfach
jeder christ und hat sich auf die bibel
bezogen wenn er denn konnte wenn er
lesen konnte dass ich auch so also das
war gar nicht eine perspektive die
denken wirklich war aber die frage
dahinter ist auch ob das gewissen denn
immer richtig liegt oder ob es auch
falsch liegen kann wenn man falsch
sozialisiert wird in einer bestimmten
kultur mit draußen werden das ist jetzt
die frage an luther oder an uns an euch
weiter gibt ja schon forschung auf
neurobiologischen forschung wie wo und
wie das gewissen angehängt ist auch im
gehirn wie das mit emotionen
zusammenhängt mit handlungs
folgenabschätzung auch mit erfahrungen
und dass das gewissen nicht vom himmel
fällt sondern entsteht und mit
erfahrungen klein kindlichen und
jugendlichen erfahrung kultur erfahrung
geprägt ist und deswegen kultur abhängig
ist das ein gewissen in einem
kriegsgebiet ob man als kindersoldat
ausgebildet wird ein anderes gewissen
ist als ein kind das in der in einer
glücklichen familie aufwächst und satt
und zufrieden zur schule geht das ist
sogar intuitiv nachvollziehbar dass der
mensch kann dass der mensch scheitern
kann
ich denke das ist in der christlichen
anthropologie einfach auch angelegt und
das hätte luther auch immer gesagt also
jeder mensch ist sie muss zb kader sagt
ja immer gerechter und sünder zugleich
ich finde das auch sehr hilfreich auch
mit blick auf luther selber also der
muss da nicht auf einem helden sockel
stehen sondern er irrte ja in bestimmten
dingen auch und ich denke das hat er
also in sein sein weltbild und sein
menschenbild auch mit einbezogen wo er
als größten irrtum würde ich sagen sein
antijudaismus also er will alles auf
jesus christus hin lesen das ganze alte
testament und kann nicht akzeptieren
dass juden das völlig anders lesen und
hat dann eine schreckliche schrift 15 43
von den juden und ihren lügen
das war ein wichtiger prozess dass die
evangelische kirche deutschland sich
davon wirklich klar distanziert hat er
irrte denke ich auch als er gesagt hat
das kam in dem film ja auch so schön das
hat nichts mit politischer freiheit zu
tun
im bauernkrieg sagt er jetzt an die
fürsten haben das recht mit starkem und
nahm und mit geballter einzuschlagen
also ich denke da irrte er auch dieses
recht haben die fürsten meines erachtens
nicht und es hat mit dem evangelium zu
tun dass wir auch spezifische
reformierter perspektive auch noch mal
unterstreichen da irrt wenn er den
bauern sagt ihr könnt für eure freiheit
kämpfen aber nehmen dafür nicht denn den
begriff des christlichen in anspruch das
hat nichts damit zu tun und ich glaube
das war ein irrtum dass da ich glaube
das war auch ein theologischer irrtum
würde ich sagen und wir haben zum glück
in der kirchengeschichte in auch auch
von katholischer seite her theologinnen
theologen gehabt die wieder darauf
aufmerksam gemacht haben dass das was
eigentlich luther auch ein anliegen war
der ganze mensch in seinem alltag sein
christsein liebt das eben deswegen auch
der ganze menschen seinen leiblichen
bezogen wo er arbeitet wo er unterdrückt
wird was er zu essen hat weil es mir
leid eigen ist oder nicht dass das mit
seinem christian zu tun hat und dass das
sitze attraktiv und den bezug des
christlichen anfang für sich in anspruch
nehmen soll noch eine letzte frage zum
gewissen an sich persönlich welche rolle
spielt das gewissen für sich in ihrem
leben bei wichtigen entscheidungen ist
das nicht instanz auf die sie sich
berufen
also für mich ist das eine instanz und
ich denke schon dass das gewissen
bedeutet dass du dir zeit nimmst in dich
rein hörst
mal von diesen ganzen stimmen die auf
dich einreden der welt oder auch von
freunden bekannten familie und versuchs
zu sagen was ist jetzt die
verantwortliche entscheidung die ich
treffen kann
in verantwortung vor mir selbst vor gott
und jetzt sage ich mal an den menschen
das hört sich ein bisschen pathetisch an
aber ich finde es gibt situationen wo du
wirklich entscheiden muss und dann eine
gewissensentscheidung triffst und ich
war er lange präsidentin der
beratungsstellen für die
kriegsdienstverweigerer das wurde auch
immer als gewissensentscheidung gesehen
und verstanden jedenfalls in
westdeutschland dass du aus
gewissensgründen den dienst an der waffe
verweigert das ist zum beispiel für mich
ein ganz großer ausdruck einer
gewissensentscheidung
für mich ist frage ich warum man nicht
einfach gesagt hat beruft ihr euch also
ich berufe mich auf die schrift und auf
die vernunft aber irgendwie irgendetwas
hatte er gegen die vernunft
er nennt sie zum beispiel auch eine [ __ ]
des teufels und man solle die augen
ausstechen und so weiter was hatte den
luther gegen die förderung wären die
vernunft nicht ein mittel das los mit
dem man losgelöst von der schrift durch
vernunft gründe und vernunft
argumentation zur erkenntnis gottes
kommen konnte
die wesentlichen grund bezüge des
menschlichen dasein sondern gottesbezug
dass wir sünder sind so in uns selber
verkrümmt dass wir nichts erkennen
können auch nicht durch die vernunft
auch die vernunft ist in sich selber
verkrümmt wochen aus recht was besonders
in sich selber verkrümmt das einen
wunderbaren ausdruck für sünder sein zu
zeigen dass sünder sei nicht heißt noch
dieses stück schwarzwälder torte zu
essen obwohl man auf diät ist aber auch
nicht irgendwie etwas mitgehen lassen im
laden sondern eine eine dasein scon die
zion in sich selber verkrümmt heißt doch
ich sehe nur mich selber ich bin auf
mich selber bezogen so entrückt woods
endlich und auch im blick ich sehe alles
was nützt es mir wie stehe ich dann da
was bringt es mir wo komme ich damit hin
und dass auch die vernunft auf sich
selbst bezogen ist und sich nicht
erleuchten lässt von dem was sie
eigentlich alleine aus ihrem selbst
bezog befreien würde nämlich dass die
anerkennung der glaube an den gott der
uns aufrichtet und den blick frei macht
in das hinaus was die anderen rundherum
sind
dazu stehen nicht zustimmen jetzt er
beruft sich gehabt die schrift und hier
gibt es diese vielfach wird von formel
also sola gratia sola fide solus
christus sola scriptura also allein die
gnade der glaube christus und die
schrift können sie mir das erläutern was
das bedeutet mit solar viele und sola
gratia und aber das finde ich schon
interessant dass er römer 328 übersetzen
sagt der gerechte wird allein aus
glauben
der sender wird allein aus glauben
gerecht und dann sagen andere allein
steht ja gar nicht im griechischen
urtext drin und dann sagt er aber um das
zu verstehen muss man dieses solo allein
da einfluss ist gemeint und wer das
nicht kapiert sagte der guckt wie die
pisten nehme ich die gucken genau so auf
diese textstelle wie ein ochse auf ein
geschlossenes scheunentor man muss das
schwer info also öffnen und verstehen
allein aus glauben nur der glaube der
glaube ist entscheidend und das ist ja
wichtig weil er sagt nicht die werke
nichts was du tust nicht ob du dich
jetzt ganz besonders gut verhältst oder
ganz viel leiste das ist entscheidend
sondern dein glaube ist entscheidend
dass du vor gott ein gerechtfertigtes
leben und dann kann ich tun muss ich
will ja das würde eher sagen in der
konsequenz in der konsequenz wenn du das
begreift dass du von gottes gnade aus
sola gratia also lebst dann wirst du
sagen jetzt will ich aber alles tun um
so zu leben wie es gott für den menschen
vorgesehen hat das ist die konsequenz
aber erst mal bist du frei weil du sagst
allein aus glauben und allein aus gottes
gnade lebe ich und die guttenberg was du
tust was du leistest ist die konsequenz
aus dieser befreienden erfahrung und der
klar bisher ist auch eine gnade
also es ist ein keine entscheidung an
geschenkt der glaube ist für ihn auch
ein geschenk und dann kannst du
natürlich sagen warum habe ich das
geschenk dann hast du das geschenk nicht
ist das nicht ungerecht das hat dann
kann weitergezogen nicht erst gott in
seiner allwissenheit der schuld
vorherbestimmt dass die einen glauben
und die anderen nicht das ist mir das
egal wie mit seinem gegner kommen
genutzt alles wie sonst auch bei toyota
hatten sich davor gescheut ich das ganz
und gar durchzudenken
aber es tropft
also das geht so dass christus also nur
christus ist derjenige der uns dem diese
gnade vermitteln kann weil gott in
christus mensch geworden christus am
kreuz für unsere sünden gestorben das
auf sich genommen wir in einem
fröhlichen tausch quasi unsere sinnhafte
existenz ihm da hinlegen können und er
in uns wohnung nimmt und er quasi auf
uns genommen hat was uns zukäme
man merkt ja gar nicht war eigentlich
will ich als sehr vieles andere zu
stellen
aber ich versuche das in der ludwig beck
matic der linie zu verfolgen und sola
scriptura ist ja eigentlich da kommt
jetzt die systematik hindurch bei mir
ist nicht 1 1 und nicht nur die schrift
sondern nur durch die schrift ist
gemeint also nur durch die schrift
erkennen wir das eben allein die gnade
ist unser land unser glaube und allein
christus also nicht die schrift
hinstellen als ein papier papst und
sagen da steht alle sind genau so ist es
geschehen und dass daran ist nur zu
halten sondern durch dass die lektüre
der schrift in einer großen freiheit wie
das mit dem allein durch gnade zieht der
geist in uns ein ist christian festersen
uns wohnungen das lesen und dann
eröffnet sich uns dieses fenster zum zur
freiheit das ist aber sagen aber mutter
hatte ich hier gar nicht so zusammen
gehalt sondern dass sie anderen späterer
jahrhunderte die gesagt haben
darauf kann man es konzerne ja schon
treffend ich finde das treffen und ist
natürlich auch eine gute formel das ist
ganz lieber merken allein die gnade
allein die schrift allein es nicht laut
sein wäre
genau
wir hatten von der vernunft kurz
gesprochen ich möchte noch wissen über
die freiheit sprechen
luther hat eine schrift geschrieben über
den freien willen
jetzt haben die gewissensfreiheit
geredet und so weiter aber er glaubte
nicht an den freien willen er hat den
menschen verglichen mit einem reittier
auf dem entweder gott sitzt oder der
teufel und wer dort oben sitzt darf mir
das kann ich mir nicht aussuchen was
macht man damit glauben sie dass
notorische theologin
damit habe ich tatsächlich mühe mir
gefällt natürlich seine schrift von der
freiheit eines christenmenschen
wesentlich bessern der sagt der
christenmensch ist ein freier herr aller
dinge und niemandem untertan nachdem der
richtige reiter auf ihn sehen und dann
sagt er aber im zweiten auch der
christenmensch ist ein dienstbarer
knecht aller dinge und jedermann
untertan und ich glaube dass das wir das
in unserem leben ja doch auch so erleben
können dass diese freiheit nicht eine
ein lieber tennis muss ist alles ist
möglich alles kann ich tun alles ist
denkbar sondern dass ich meine freiheit
immer auch nutze für einen bestimmten
zweck ich würde sagen aus christlicher
sicht nutze ich meine freiheit im sinne
der nächstenliebe in im sinne des
gemeinwohls oder nicht als pure egomanie
und da ist schon die frage wer treibt
mich eigentlich in dieser freiheit ist
es der teufel der mich treibt mich würde
sagen der teufel treibt die freiheit
immer dazu dass die freiheit nur für
mich genutzt wird für meine egomanie
dass ich mehr habe dass ich mir schaffen
kann
eine freiheit die sage ich mal von gott
getrieben ist es eine freiheit die das
gemeinwohl sieht die anderen sieht und
die frage wie kann ich meine gaben die
ich habe eigentlich in die gemeinschaft
einbringen wie kann ich meine freiheit
nutzen für andere aber wie kann ich mich
überhaupt noch schuldig machen oder
verantwortung übernehmen wenn ich keine
freiheit haben und nicht bestimmen kann
ob ich jetzt der teufel reitet oder gott
richtet diese schrift sehr ein vom
unfreien welt als ich ja das finde ich
auch aus seinen sünden begriff
ebendieses ähnlich selber verkrümmte wie
befreit man sich da raus und ich habe
also ich finds auch so vor dem
hintergrund der neurobiologischen
forschung spannend die er sich sehr mit
dem der willensfreiheit
auseinandergesetzt hat und sich überlegt
hat wenn alles kausal beziehungen sind
die den menschen in seiner biologischen
existenz bestimmen warum dann nicht das
gehirn wo
mazda ein einfallstor für wirkliche
freiheit und mich überzeugt nicht einer
sehr gut nachvollziehen dass dieses in
sich selber verkrümmte das garnicht
verantwortlichkeit ist im sinne von du
bist und du hast dich mal so entschieden
so zu werden menschen werden in
situationen hinein geboren in familien
in kulturen in kriegs- friedens
situationen und dass man da etwas
erleben muss was man selber nicht machen
das einem befreit aus diesem
getriebensein vom eigenen ich die
philosophin alles mit hat vom fetten
erbarmungslosen ego gesprochen und sie
war gar nicht christin das alles
durchdringt und durchtränkt und dass da
etwas geschehen muss was ich mir nicht
selber machen kann weil ich immer schon
dieser egomanie drin bin
das überzeugt mich auch empirisch sehe
es nach ungerechte kühe ja aber ist doch
so ist es nicht ungerecht auf der welt
war bin ich was machen können aber das
ist ein anderer gedanke dazu gucken und
zu sagen es geschieht es geschehen dinge
in dieser welt ist ungerecht
ich glaube dahinter können wir nicht
zurück was wie wir das damit gott in
beziehung bringen das ist ein schritt
weiter darüber hinaus das interessiert
mich jetzt nur ganz kurz genau klären
wir doch gleich mal theorie ja ich habe
ich glaube nicht dass gott ungerechte
verhältnisse schafft oder dass gott leid
schickt und sagt jetzt hier die wenn
jetzt mal vom tsunami betroffenen die
von einem bürgerkrieg und die nächste
von der krebserkrankung und die anderen
können frei lebendes das ist doch nicht
ein gottesbild dann wäre gott ein
marionettenspieler der sagt hier mal ein
bisschen daher immer ein bisschen da und
wir werden alle solche playmobil figuren
die gott setzt sozusagen in einem spiel
ich denke schon da hat gott uns in
verantwortung gesetz als menschen also
wir menschen wissen verantwortlich leben
und mein gott des bildes das dass gott
wenn wir leid ertragen müssen wenn wir
mit den herausforderungen des lebens
konfrontiert sind dass gott uns dann die
kraft schenken kann im glauben mit
diesem leid zu leben dass ich dieses
leid mit einer haltung des glaubens
annehme und mit diesem leid auch
überlebe und trotz des leids dieser welt
und trotz der ungerechtigkeiten
überleben wird die ungerechtigkeit
natürlich als christa nicht stehen
lassen wollen sondern immer versuchen
gegen diese ungerecht
ich kann als christin anzutreten ohne
absolviert aber die frage warum es ihn
überhaupt so zu und her geht in dieser
welt dass die einen leid erfahrungen
verarbeiten müssen und die anderen viel
viel weniger
ich glaube dass gott in der erschaffung
der welt gesagt hat und jetzt zieh ich
mich auch ein stück weit zurück ich an
der nicht jeden fehltritt ich komme
nicht gleich mit blitz und donner wenn
jemand sie schuldig machen menschen
genau das sind ich glaube schon dass das
auch verhältnisse sind zum teil von
menschen getrieben mit co2 ausstoß und
klimaveränderungen zum teil aus der
natur verhältnissen heraus getrieben
ich glaube dass ich gott in der welt ein
stück zurück gezogen hat und nicht mit
seiner allmacht überall rein funkt und
dass deswegen verhältnisse entstehen
konnten durch menschen durch die natur
die ungerecht sind und das ist unser
auftrag dann zu sagen ok wo es könnte
womit wir uns einsetzen damit wir bis
jetzt rechne er würde sagen wir sprechen
jetzt über die grundfragen der theologie
die menschen seit luther und mehr
vorgesprochen habe ob dies nicht so eine
lockere antwort gibt aber ich muss sagen
ich mich hat man sehr überzeugt
bonhoeffer der gesagt hat die
herausforderung der theologie ist gottes
allmacht wir sagen gott der allmächtige
und gottes ohnmacht gott stirbt selbst
da am kreuz wir glauben ja dass jesus
christus am kreuz gestorben
es ist gott selbst ist also diese
allmacht und diese ohnmacht
zusammenzudenken das bleibt eine
herausforderung da gibt es keine antwort
sie sagt so ist es sondern das ist was
was uns ja als christen auch umtreibt
wie kann gott selbst da leiden und
sterben warum kommt da nicht der blitz
und donner sagt jetzt ist aber schluss
damit und bei luther war das ja auch so
15 05 hatte ein gewitter erlebt und es
sind die krise und die hat ihn eigens
dazu geführt dass er dann wurde
mich würde interessieren ist das bei
ihnen auch so solche grenzsituationen
und krisen bestärkt sie doch der glaube
drin oder fangen sie an zu zweifeln
ich muss ich sagen hat er glaube da
immer bestärkt ich habe mich gerade in
den krisensituationen nicht gezweifelt
also zweifel kennt jeder mensch ich bin
es merkwürdig wenn jemand sagt ich habe
im leben gezweifelt also hast du mal
denkst was wäre eigentlich wenn es gott
gar nicht gäbe
was wäre wenn das alles von menschen
erdacht ist ich denke das muss jeder
glauben da auch mal sich dem aussetzt
ich glaube dass jeder atheist sich mal
der frage aussetzen muss und wenn es
gott doch gebe und dass jeder gläubige
gläubige mensch sich einmal der frage
auch mindestens aussetzen muss was wenn
es gott nicht gäbe aber gerade in phasen
sozusagen der anfechtung oder der der
also leid finde ich jetzt fast so groß
in unserem kontext aber der der schweren
zeiten im leben da habe ich meinen
glauben eigentlich immer als bestärkung
erlebt weil wir ja auch eine tradition
haben von vätern und müttern im glauben
die über tausende von jahren mit diesen
herausforderungen gelebt haben und dann
kannst du eben in einer notsituation
worte finden die größer sind als du
selber psalm 23 ob ich schon wanderte im
finsteren tal fürchte ich kein unglück
ich bin ja nicht die erste die so eine
situation erlebt und menschen vor uns
haben eben glauben da auch die kraft
gefunden das finde ich oft gut dass es
besser und größer als diese ganzen
betroffenheits bekundungen die da
spontan entstehen
wir helfen solchen situationen rituale
aber die reformierte kirche hat viele
rituale wieder abgeschafft war das ein
fehler
na ja sie hat das abgeschafft was sie
dachte wird allen übergestülpt die hat
die reformierte tradition also gerade in
der schweiz auch in einem sehr großen
ausmaß die freiheit des einzelnen sehr
hoch geschätzt und gesagt das ist ja
auch noch gar nicht so alt das ritual
oder das glaubensbekenntnis im
gottesdienst das wurde erst im 19
jahrhundert als pfarrer die geprägt
waren von der aufklärung von den
naturwissenschaften gesagt haben dieses
glaubensbekenntnis der gott der
allmächtige der erschaffen hat christus
von der jungfrau maria geboren
hinabgefahren das kann ich nicht glauben
wie kann ich das im gottesdienst jeden
sonntag und um die kirche nicht zu
spalten in eine gruppe von fahrern die
das konto und eine wie es nicht konnte
hat haben die schweizer die thurgauer
zuerst und dann andere kantone gesagt
okay wir lassen euch frei
also ist nicht eine abschaffung der
rituale sind eine freilassung der
rituale sucht in euro gottesbeziehung
vor allem mit eurem an der bibel
schulden wissen sucht euch und für eure
gemeinde
die rituale die die für euch wichtig und
deswegen auch bekenntnisse überhaupt das
ist ja nicht eine abschaffung eine
lossagung von bekenntnissen dass die
reformierte kirche keine bekenntnisse
hat sondern die die aufgabe der aufruf
dazu immer wieder sich mit dem
biblischen texten auseinanderzusetzen
und die bekenntnisse zu formulieren die
hier und jetzt uns weiterhelfen
selbstbestimmung selbstverantwortung im
glauben so so verstehe ich ja ja ich
muss sagen ich finde es manchmal
hilfreich diese bekenntnisse ich
natürlich auch mal briefe die sagen das
kann man so nicht mehr formulieren das
müsste man umformulieren weil ich denke
gerade das apostolische
glaubensbekenntnis in so wenigen worten
zu sagen was wir eigentlich glauben und
das seit 375 glaube ich oder wann es
entstanden ist 325 dass das so lange
durchgehalten hat und in allen kirchen
dieser welt gebetet werden kann oder
bekannt werden kann als eine essenz
unseres glaubt das finde ich oft
hilfreich ich meine wer von uns sage ich
jetzt mal wenn wir eine kommission in
der ekd hätten die jetzt ein neues
bekenntnis formulieren soll das würde
wahrscheinlich acht jahre mindestens
dauern und 15 leitz ordner mit
vorschlägen und veränderungsvorschläge
bringen insofern kann ich mich in diese
rituale und in solche alten text einfach
manchmal auch fallen lassen und sagen
ich weiß dass jetzt im moment auch nicht
besser aber ich kann es mal sowas spiel
für mich mit aufnehmen als meine
tradition
aber das geht nur wenn es deine
tradition ist und menschen die diesen
tradition ab traditions- abbruch
miterlebt haben oder deren kinder der
die sich nicht mehr fallen lassen können
weil das nichts mehr ist das für sie
trägt wie de ist es schwierig solche
alten formulierungen die er auch noch
vertraut sind und ob man da nicht sagt
das haben wir auch versucht bei den
reformierten hier nochmal anzuknüpfen
sagen wollen wir das neu formulieren das
apostolische glaubensbekenntnis sind
worten die kurt marti zum beispiel
vorgeschlagen hat oder wollte sagen
versucht eure eigenen glauben zu
bekennen ist zu formulieren für mich ist
das schon auch ein stück freiheit zu
sagen mit menschen die nicht da
anknüpfen können was glaubt ihr denn was
ist euch wichtig hat man mit einer
konfirmandengruppe dieses
glaubensbekenntnis durch
durchbuchstabiert und sie gefragt
streckt die hand auf wenn ihr wenn jetzt
glauben könnt und jeden halbsatz
anvisiert war ein halbsatz wo alle die
sagen könnte
konnten das glaube ich und es war ich
glaube und alles andere konnten sie sich
nicht einigen
heißt das jetzt sie sind nicht in dieser
traditionsgemeinschaft ja ein stück aber
alle haben sehnsucht und verlassen sich
auf etwas und ich lese auch als meine
aufgabe herauszufinden was ist es denn
wie können wir das heute neu formulieren
und wie können wir es in bezug bringen
mit den biblischen texten dass es eben
nicht irgendetwas ist sondern etwas was
auch und wieder ganz neu in dieser
tradition steht ja wobei ich manchmal
zweifel habe ob wir heute wirklich
besser formulieren können als unsere
väter und mütter angelaufen ob das neue
immer hilfreich ist also ich halte
stärker mit der tradition aber ich bin
halt lutherische präpariert dass da ein
unterschied
vielleicht war das auch ein
erfolgsgeheimnis von luther seine
rhetorik nein ich sind seine
rhetorischen künstlich und wie er seine
flugschriften und eins ist glaube ich
schon vor ihm viele reformator jan hus
zum beispiel der lärm wird in haft
unterscheide hafen luther hat es
geschafft er in bebra sagen ja nur ich
hatte sehr ähnliche idee luther schon zu
seiner zeit aber m fehlten zwei dinge
erstens ein fürst der ihnen geschützt
hätte also hätte keine weltliche macht
ihn geschützt hatte und das drucken also
luther war auch so erfolgreich müssen
wir ja sagen weil er tatsächlich seine
flugschriften sagen ja viele waren
schneller in der welt als die zensur
überhaupt hierher kam beim reichstag sie
heute wird er wahrscheinlich auch
getwittert aber beim reichstag zu worms
1521 neuen worms und wollten formulieren
was nun geschehen war da war schon
flugschrift in der welt mit diesem
berühmten satz hier stehe ich ich kann
nicht anders gott helfe mir amend ob er
das so gesagt hat wissen wir gar nicht
aber es war schon die kunde im lande
unser luther hat gestanden wie eine eins
sozusagen
aber es war wichtig und auch
zeitschriften nun in deutsch und kurz
und seine seine kollegen professoren
haben alle gesagt das kann nichts gutes
sein wenn es sich lange und latein ist
aber die leute konnten es lesen und
dadurch waren merck mächtig und er war
einfach auch ein sprachgenie also ich
habe die negativen seiten genannt aber
wenn man seine übersetzung am see
revidiert für 2017 oder sie wurde noch
mal genau durchgeschaut ganz oft ist sie
20 17 fassung zurück zu luther selbst
gegangen weil er einfach sprache mächtig
war und man kann das sehr schön sehen
er streicht dann durchsucht ein neues
wort sucht noch mal ein neues wort bis
zum lebensende
gleich und hat die deutsche sprache
geschaffen ich finde auch manche
begriffe lückenbüßer
darauf muss man erst mal kommen
lückenbüßer was das für begriffs oder
geizhals was das was als ingrid mädchen
ist auch diese körperlich lehrer haben
sich zerstört
und da ist er einfach genial dass man
dank die deutsche sprache gebracht
absolut das ewig neidlos jetzt können
wir jetzt noch die zuschauer hinzu naja
das reformationsjubiläum geht ja weiter
nach diesem jahr in der schweiz hat
ulrich zwingli den 15
er fängt jetzt richtig mit politischen
fragen uns dazu auch einen kurzen
filmbeitrag ulrich zwingli zürcher
reformator sei ein ambitiöses ziel der
ganzen schweiz eine neue religion
verordnen
doch der priester löst viel mehr aus als
nur eine erneuerung der kirche erklärt
historiker christian moser der formation
wirkte in den bereichen der politik oder
kultur wie ein katalysator der sie neue
entwicklungen aufgenommen und
beschleunigt verdichtet hat ein beispiel
ist zum beispiel das bildungswesen
universität zürich ihre vorgänger
institution ist eine ganz direkte folge
der reformation auch in lausanne und
genf entstehen in der folge
universitäten welche die schweiz bis
heute prägen zwingen dieser kirche und
staat in enger zusammenarbeit ein staat
habe die verpflichtung für das volk mut
zu sorgen
damit war der grundstein gelegt die
moderne staatliche sozialhilfe vor der
reformation war dass er eine zufällige
angelegenheit im bereich dieser mohsen
gebens in der reformationszeit hat man
das teil verstaatlicht monaten erstellt
überlegt wer kommt in genuss von solchen
leistungen und hat das auch überprüft
man wandte somit ungefähr dieselben
prinzipien an die auch heute noch gelte
zwink liegt der reform geist
unvermindert aktuell sein appell zum
selbst denken ein grundwert einer
modernen freiheitlichen gesellschaft ja
fast traut der zwingende war das
sozusagen die fortsetzung von luther mit
politischen mitteln nein es war nicht
einer dinge hat ganz viel von luther
aufgenommen hat sich lothar auch sehr
verpflichtet gefühlt hat sich luther
eigentlich auch nahe geführt ist oder
nicht immer erwidert von luther seite ja
aber er hat sich in derselben tradition
gesehen hat dann andere betonung gesetzt
auch von seiner herkunft her da war wo
man ist für luther war die vernunft und
das selber denken nicht nur das selber
glauben auch immer ein
es war ein wichtiger teil seiner
tradition oder klingeltöne dinge die für
zwinge war das wichtig und deswegen auch
diese möglichkeit auch dieses dieses
individualismus und das politische das
kommt aus seiner überzeugung auch
natürlich aus seiner biografie sohn
eines stadtplans auswählt haus ins
föderalistische gemeinde systemen darin
verwurzelt gesehen wie entscheide
gefällt werden diskutiert werden im dorf
und seine überzeugung dass sich
menschliche gerechtigkeit die für die
der staat hier auf erden zuständig ist
an der göttlichen gerechtigkeit messen
lassen muss immer das menschliche
gerechtigkeit arm und schadhaft brecht
haft ist und immer wieder bezogen werden
muss gemessen werden muss an der
göttliche gerechtigkeit weil sie sonst
abfällt noch mehr abbilden wer kennt
sich mit der göttlichen gerechtigkeit
aus die kirche also hat die kirche den
auftrag wirklich dem staat unter die
arme zu greifen und auf die finger zu
schauen dass dieser bezug gewahrt bleibt
und damit hat er zb so etwas wie der
sozialhilfe erfunden damit hat der staat
hat sich auch viel übernommen weil der
sich diesen auftrag auch zu eigen
gemacht hat genau das war daneben die
staatliche sozialhilfe wären sie ja in
deutschland viel stärker die diakonie
bei den kirchengemeinden
es ist in der schweiz statt über
staatlich geworden
absolut den übereinstimmung mit dem
reformierten gedankengut das ist dass
die armen arm im zusammenarbeiten
aber gibt es denn heute noch differenzen
die relevant sind also es gab diesen
diesen abend maß streit zum beispiel der
ist ja geschlichtet darüber gemacht so
lange noch nicht so lange her
wer bekommt das 15 29 haben sich eben
zwingen die butter getroffenen marburg
zum religions- gespräche und haben sich
in 14 punkten geeinigt und dann bei der
frage wie jesus christus präsent ist im
abendmahl
da haben sie sich gestritten ob das
wirklich blut und wirklich dass nadal so
dass wir jetzt die katholiken die sagen
dass es ganz real waren sich das entlud
und leib christi
luther hat gesagt christus ist präsent
im abendmahl in mit und unter brot und
wein als geheimnis und zwingli von der
vernunft er hat gesagt das ist schlicht
ein zeichen ein symbol aber al christus
ist präsent im abendmahl aber nicht in
brot und wein sondern innere wahrheit in
seinem geiste der ist genauso real
präsident aber eben nicht in diesen
substanzen die wir nachher mit denen wir
nachher von dem machen können zum
beispiel sondern wirkliche zusammen mit
dem folge dass darüber müssen wir noch
diskutieren
das ist für die literarisch wer zuhört
was ich jetzt sagen ja dann bin ich hab
ich jetzt wirklich katholisch
wahrscheinlicher aus heimsheim ist haben
sie aber sie schreiben ja ja wir haben
nachher
ich hab mal in basel ein
abendmahlsgottesdienst gehalten dabei
ist die liturgie gesungen und hinterher
wurde mir gesagt dass vettel sieht doch
sehr katholisch der pfarrer weiter
hinter zwingen und wird da konnten sich
auch menschlich nicht so furchtbar gut
leiden weil luther hat wohl tiefe
sächsisch gesprochen und zwingen
schweizerdeutsch und die beiden kamen
auch glaube ich menschlich sonst hätten
sich vielleicht geeinigt aber irgendwie
wollten in die jetztzeit kommen 1973 gar
nicht weit von rage haben sich dann die
europäischen lutherischen reformierten
und unierten christen geeinigt dass
trotz dieser differenz im verständnis
des abendmahls wir uns als kirchen
anerkennen wir unsere ämter anerkennen
und deshalb auch zusammen abend feiern
können und ich denke seitdem gibt es so
ein evangelisch sein dass manchmal jongs
und von differenzen hat
vielleicht ob man das boot zum vornehmen
könnte das wäre gerade eine anfechtung
aber als die lutherische theologie denn
ich glaube in der gemeinde ist das
reformierte also es gibt leichte
differenzen aber wir können gut
miteinander abendmahl von jesus schön
das ist wir bleiben noch ein bisschen in
der schweiz aber gegen von zürich nach
genf zu dem französischen juristen
johannes calvin der da 15 41 minuten
später dieses genf zu einem kleinen
gottesstaat umgebaut hat zu einem
reformierten ruhm mit strenger city und
arbeitsmoral er hat nachgesagt arbeit
ist gottesdienst auch etwas das so weit
ich weiß bei ludwig müssen angelegt war
und der soziologe max weber hat der scp
so entwickelt dass der kapitalismus und
das profitstreben schon im
protestantismus angelegt sei und kaum
hatte danach gesagt man erkennt die von
gott auserwählten an ihrem reichtum und
so weiter was ist denn an dieser these
an dieser verbindung vom kapitalismus
schon protestantismus die die weber hat
ist da was dran oder ist das ja es ist
schon sehr vereinfacht auch also bin
auch keine kamen spezialisten aber ich
glaube dass man erkennt die christen
einigung reicht das hätte er so nie
gesagt
ihm war es wichtig was du ja auch
angesprochen hat ist wenn man glaubt
dann ist es nicht wurscht wie man
nachher liebt sondern dass man christ
ist und sein gewissen an die schrift
hängt muss auswirkungen haben im
täglichen leben und das nichts anderes
war calvin sun legen dass man sieht dass
da eine christengemeinde ist dass man
das auch in ihrem leben sieht und dass
die gesetze nicht abgetan werden die
gesetze im alten testament nicht einfach
durch gestrichen oder erfüllt sind und
dann kann man häkchen setzen sondern
dass die für christen und christin noch
mal eine neue bedeutung erhalten weil
sie gerade erfüllt werden können
von christin und wissen dass mit dem
reichtum und nicht profitstreben
protestantismus und profitstreben
sondern protestantismus und arbeitsethos
wenig und weil man den reichtum als
christ nicht zur schau stellen soll
was macht man mit dem geld das man
verdient durch ein ehrliches und solides
arbeitsethos man investiert wieder in
sein geschäft und das ist nicht um des
profits willen sondern weil man einfach
anständig
und verantwortungsbewusst wirtschaften
will aber das ist sehr sehr vereinfacht
und ich glaube hält auch empirisch nicht
stand aber trotzdem es ist jedenfalls
nicht dass profitstreben und nicht dass
gottes segen am kontostand abgelesen
werden werden soll dass mir niemand
meinen gewesen aber trotzdem so für mich
aus der distanz ich habe mich gefragt
inwiefern prägte das unsere mentalität
von heute also wenn ich denke an diese
selbstoptimierung die wir überall sehen
konnte fehlt diese diese idee von
verzicht bei den männern zum beispiel an
dieses leistungsdenken ist das kann man
so weit zurückgehen oder ist das also
die lutheraner ist es glaube ich schon
noch einmal ein bisschen anders jetzt
sagen also der weg könnte aber die
bilder von calvin und luther auch
nebeneinander hängen also luther waschen
mensch der sehr sehr gerne gelebt hat
gegessen getrunken hat der sexualität
sehr geschätzt hat also das war schon
jemand der auch sage ich mal die schönen
dinge des lebens er genossen hat als
calvin das würde ich das würde ich so
sehen diese charikar mit diese strenge
nicht tanzen nicht singen ich also das
ist mir auch echt sehr sehr fremd bilder
keine musik das ist also die lutheraner
ein bisschen lebenslustiger würde ich
sagen aber bei calvin das denke ich auch
so weit können wir nicht gehen die
prosperity gospel ist heute gibt es
gerade in afrikanischen ländern aber
auch in nordamerika oder in korea das
wieder gesagt wird also wenn du viel
betet wenn du vom lebst dann wirst du
auch reich werden und gesund bleiben
das widerspricht für mich grundsätzlich
dem evangelium bei jesus nun sehr klar
gemacht hat krankheit ist nicht eine
folge deiner sünden seiner eltern
sondern der mensch mit seiner krankheit
kann sich ganz gott zu wenden
und es ist nicht am erfolg deines lebens
abzusehen ob du vor gott ein guter
mensch bist sondern gott wendet sich den
menschen zu das ist das allererste also
das würde ich als eine falsche
konsequenz aus dem evangelium sehen und
ich denke dass max weber insofern recht
hat als es ein gesamt evangelisches
berufsethos gibt da gibt es von luther
seinen schönen satz also du kannst doch
nicht dasitzen und warten dass die ein
gebratenes hühnchen in das maul fliegt
sagte sondern du bist schon mit seinen
gaben dazu da deine gaben auch in die
gesellschaft einzubringen und deshalb
hat jeder mensch eine berufung und damit
einen beruf
er hätte nie von einem job mit dem man
einfach geld macht gesprochen sondern
wenn du was kannst ist das dein beruf
und der beruf der markt die den besen
schwingt ist für die gesellschaft
genauso viel wert wie der beruf des
fürsten der das land regieren kann also
daher kommt schon eine haltung dass du
sagst ich kann was und das was ich kann
das bringe ich aber auch ein nur wenn du
krank bist mit behinderung leben muss
dann bist du ja trotzdem etwas wert und
hast vielleicht die gabe des zuhörens
der die gesellschaft auch braucht also
dass die arbeit diesen stellenwert hat
wie in unserer zeit das geht schon
wissen auf luther und calvin und zwingen
den ku zurück weil wir fragen uns die
ganze zeit was machst du denn wenn wir
uns kennenlernen und meint damit den
beruf und das definiert uns eigentlich
aber die kinder nicht nur den schein
also nicht nur den sozialen status eben
gerade nicht der wir fragen was bist du
und wissen dann wo wir in ein
einschätzen könig aber luther und auch
karin hätten gesagt die markt die den
besen schwingt hat auch hat ein
berufsethos das kann man gut machen oder
das kann man schlecht machen und wir
sind jetzt unserem selbstverständnis als
christen christine schuldig dass wir das
was wir auch immer tun gut machen und
dann ist es vor gott gut egal auf
welchen sozialen status wäre damit sich
und das ja heute gerade nicht unbedingt
so will sagt zur sozialen frage ist im
luthertum dann eben dieses kastenwesen
entstanden abschluss nichts 15 23 und
das heißt wenn du was tust und verdient
geld damit dann gibst du aber auch für
die die nicht können die sind nämlich in
der gemeinde auch etwas wert genauso
viel wert
und dann gibt es zehn männer jeden
sonntag leider noch keine frauen aber
nicht der pfarrer sondern zehn männer
aus der gesellschaft und auch nicht nur
die reichen sondern ist auch ein
handwerker dabei land ein bauer dabei
und die entscheiden wer wer für sich
selbst sorgen kann also subsidiarität
und wer nicht für sich sorgen kann für
den sorgt die gemeinschaften finde ich
also schön und das heißt dann zum
schluss und deshalb wird das betteln
abgeschafft
das finde ich sehr gut also für die
menschen soll so gesorgt werden dass 70
nicht versorgen können sich darauf
verlassen können dass die gemeinschaft
für sie sorgt das ist ein gutes
sozialsystem und da braucht dann auch
keiner mehr betteln
das hat dann zwingen ja auch gemacht mit
der losen ordnung etwas verstärken
werden soll
das habe ich eine ketzerische frage
diese idee zurückzugehen zu den quellen
zur schrift zum mord war das vielleicht
auch eine
wegbereitung für fundamentalistische
tendenzen wie wir es in evangelischen
kirchen evangelikalen kirchen haben zum
beispiel auch bei den kreationisten zum
beispiel die dann sagen die ariston die
motive härtesten sechs tagen erschaffen
das nicht sehen weil luther ja gesagt
hat du sollst selberdenken
fundamentalismus möchte nicht dass die
leute selber denken parlamentarismus
sagt glaubt was dir gesagt wird oder
glaubt oder china
nein was dir gesagt wird also wer sagt
ich kann weil die die
schöpfungsgeschichte lesen der sieht
auch das ist eine zweite
schöpfungsgeschichte gibt dass das
unterschiedliche erzählungen geht und
ich glaube luther und auch kabinen und
zwinge die den lucky anbindung die
hätten große freude an der historisch
kritische methode der bibelauslegung
wenn sie wüssten was wir heute wissen
wie die biblischen bücher wann sie
entstanden sind
daran hätten die glaube ich einen ganz
großen spaß auch das miteinander zu
diskutieren wie sind sie entstanden was
bedeuten sie uns und dass sie nicht von
gott von oben mit dem finger diktiert
sind das kann niemand durch halten der
selber denkt weil du da sehen kannst
dass die schriften zu unterschiedlichen
zeiten von unterschiedlichen autoren
entstanden sind blut hat schon geglaubt
es gibt nur eine richtige interpretation
dieser schrift er hat schon eher waren
das lag auch an seinem charakter sie
überzeugt dass er ist ein richtiges aber
er hätte auch gesagt auch im über
einklang mit den anderen armaturen also
wenn er zum wort zurückgeht dann geht
wirklich zum wort zurück und nicht zum
buchstaben also zum einen tiefer als
diese deutsche übersetzung die auch wenn
sie die looser besetzung ist vor mir
liegt tiefer hinein zu historisch
kritische methode wurde das muss das
entstanden wie welche manuskripte welche
übersetzung welcher situation und dann
hätten alle reformatoren darauf
verwiesen dass das wort gottes nicht die
bibel ist sondern christus und die bibel
lediglich die krippe in der christus
liegt aber das wort gottes geschieht
wenn wir an uns wenn wir die biblischen
texte lesen und ist nicht einfach so
hier auf dem tisch vorfinden ich möchte
eins sagen auch nutzer aber gar nicht so
solist wir jetzt manchmal da steht so
das gibt die schönsten szenen dass sie
in wittenberg eben zusammen kam mit
bugenhagen mit mir land schon mit
anderen die am 12 jahre beispielsweise
an der übersetzung des alten testaments
zusammengearbeitet und immer wieder
gesucht was ist die richtige
interpretation das wird erzählt dass er
sich haben
von einem metzger ein schaf ausnehmen
lassen um die richtigen begriffe zu
finden ist bieder und bürger für das
hebräische was heißt das denn alles dann
wieder und wieder überlegt die
übersetzung ist nicht richtig
also luther hat schon auch mit anderen
kommuniziert ist nicht nur dass er
kleiner meilenstein nicht nur ein
bisschen schon aber es sind schon jetzt
hat man also diese bibel gehabt auf
deutsch alle konnten das lesen warum
braucht man dann ist heute noch eine
kirche überhaupt und pfarrer oder
pfarrerin warum löst man das nicht
einfach auf und sagt hier das richtige
treten
[Gelächter]
warum das ist ja schon auch ein eine
störung dass man sagt ja ich bin christ
verstehe mich als christ aber ich
brauche keine kirche ich kann
sonntagmorgen in den wald gehen und die
vöglein sehen würden die sonne scheint
und so für mich also packte kirche ist
das äußere mittel durch den durch das
gott gemeinschaft haben die will dass
die menschen gemeinschaft haben mit
christus und mit ihm und was mir immer
sehr wichtig ist ist dass ich in der
kirchlichen gemeinschaft menschen habe
welche die dinge anders sehen also die
mich daran hindern zu denken ich hätte
jetzt die ganze wahrheit mit löffeln
gefressen und dass wir nicht als
einzelne den christlichen glauben haben
sondern als gemeinschaft den glauben in
wort und in tat das heißt dass wir
darüber streiten können wie wir
biblische texte und biblische inhalte
verstehen aber auch dass wir zusammen
etwas tun können füreinander und
miteinander
dafür ist die gemeinschaft die ja auf
erden christus auf erden darstellt die
gemeinschaft die kirche ist der christus
wie er hier auf erden existiert und das
finde ich schon eine herausforderung die
man alleine nicht stemmen kann und auch
nicht stimmen sollte aber dazu braucht
es kein fahrer naja das doch aber jetzt
sagen
die kirche ist eben nicht mehr die
mittleren des heils also dass das bricht
natürlich die macht der
mittelalterlichen kirche die sagt nur
wenn ihr zur kirche gehört dann habt ihr
überhaupt zugang zu gott zum heil das
bricht die reformation dem sie alle
sagen die reformation du kannst ganz
direkt selbst die bibel lesen du kannst
direkt zu gott beten du brauchst keine
heils mittler der kirche und trotzdem
würden sie alle sagen ohne gemeinschaft
kein christ sein
ich kann zwar im wald singen aber das
lied großer gott wir loben dich also
gott loben ist eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe
und die gemeinschaft war von anfang an
da also jesus ist nicht allein durch
israel palästina gewandert wir können
sagen von anfang an hat diese
mahlgemeinschaft die tischgemeinschaft
ist symbol des christseins gleich nach
dem tod von jesus nach der auferstehungs
erfahrung gründeten sich erste gemeinden
also gemeinschaft gehört zum christsein
dazu ich kann zwar ganz allein die bibel
lesen aber trotzdem will ich in der
gemeinde sein und da ist dann auch
christus präsent und das finde ich so
schön das ist das beste argument gegen
das papsttum weil er sagt wenn wir sagen
christus ist präsent in der gemeinde
dann braucht jemand der präsent ist kein
stellvertreter also brauchen wir keinen
papst und die pfarrerinnen und pfarrer
das ist bei uns auch kein weil status
die werden von der gemeinde sozusagen
ins sand das ist jedenfalls augsburger
lutherische bekenntnis 1530 die werden
von der gemeinde entsandt damit sie
lernen an der universität dass das
evangelium recht verkündigt und die
sakramente taufe und abendmahl recht
verwaltet werden evangeliums gemäss das
ist eine beauftragung dass es keine weil
die sie abhebt von den anderen sondern
sie werden sozusagen von der gemeinde
entsandt die rechte lehre vertreten zu
können
aber wir sagen priestertum aller
getauften also andere dürfen auch
mitreden und damit es nicht ein großes
chaos gibt weil alle zur gleichen zeit
mit rednern ist ja auch nichts dass es
um der ordnung halber sich muss dass die
ein entsandt werden und auch sich die
kriegen zeit um sich ein paar jahre
wirklich mit dem zu beschäftigen und die
gemeinde kann dann auch erwarten dass da
was zurückkommt dass sie da was auch
theologisch wieder zurückerhalten wozu
sie diesen menschen dann wo zudem zeit
gegeben haben sie sind ja auch
theologische geschäftsführerin am
zentrum für kirchen entwicklung
jetzt werden die kirchen immer leerer
wir müssen sie sich dann entwickeln
damit die jungen wieder zurückkommen
also da werde ich auch mal fragen was
verstehen sie unter kirche die
klassischen kirchen die gottesdienste
sonntagmorgen 9 bis 10 tatsächlich die
sind nicht mehr so voll wie sie zum
beispiel zu in notzeiten sind wenn etwas
passiert dann sind sie wieder voll aber
deswegen will ich doch nicht dass die
situation die gesellschaftliche
situation wieder so ist dass es die
menschen in die kirche treibt ich sehe
und freue mich sehr daran dass kirche
ganz anderen orten aufspringt wo
durchaus auch junge menschen sehen wo
wir vielleicht jetzt nicht spontan sagen
würden da ist kirche das kirche in
fabrikhallen stattfindet das kirche in
kaffeehäusern stattfindet kirche im sinn
von das wort gottes verkündigen oder
über das wort gottes reden oder über um
das wort gottes ringen in meinem alltag
gemeinschaft haben singen feiern
gottesdienst feiern auch wenn man es
vielleicht auch gar nicht so nennen
würde
ich sehe gerade vor dem hintergrund
dessen das traditionelle form vielleicht
wissen zurückgehen ein eine große
öffnung für neue formen von teheran
da bin ich ja ganz dabei aber ich mich
versah ich möchte natürlich auch den
gottesdienst so verändern in den
traditionellen die hilfe wird damit die
menschen eine sehnsucht anne h hier muss
man sagen in einer großen wunderbaren
schönen kirche nehmen wir jetzt mal
zürich grossmünster mit einer großen
gemeinde zusammen zu singen und zu beten
das ist natürlich wunderschön und ich
möchte dass die gottesdienste so sind
das leute sagen da muss ich bestimmt
spätestens sind vier wochen wieder hin
und nicht erst weihnachten also sollten
die seien jetzt nochmals unsere
leitfrage zurück welches erbe hat dann
die reformation in den köpfen und in der
kultur hinterlassen ich selbst bin
konfessionslos wo würden sie sagen bin
ich trotzdem noch stark geprägt von
dieser revolution die passiert ist und
für diesen der reformation von
lothringen carine und co
also ihre deutsche sprache mit dem
leichten ihr berufsethos sie sitzen ja
obwohl sie eigentlich ein bisschen krank
sind
das ist berufsethos das mitgegeben wird
sie tun etwas in ihrem beruf aus der
gemeinschaft zugute kommt nicht nur
einige wie sie möglichst viel geld für
sich scheffeln sondern das ist eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe über das fernsehen
bildung zu vermitteln und bildung ist
für sie auch ein hohes gut also das sind
alles auswirkungen der reformation die
auch an ihnen als konfessionslos um zu
merken sind sogar noch einen schritt
weiter gehen sagen die tatsache dass sie
konnte so sind ist ein erbe der
reformation hält das ist mein neuer alt
ist diese freiheit haben so eine wissens
glaubensfreiheit und auch die bildung
dazu nochmal sich zu überlegen und
selber zu denken und also sie sind
eigentlich ein lebendes beispiel für das
erbe der letzte kurze frage was bist du
denn
nicht passieren damit sie den glauben
verlieren ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen
ich denke ganz oft an meine großmutter
die ist in pommern zurückgeblieben das
der mann wurde nach sibirien verschleppt
wurden vergewaltigt haben alles verloren
und sind dann zu fuß 1946 ohne irgendwas
in den westen gekommen
meine großmutter hat da gestanden beim
gulasch kochen und hat wer nur den
lieben gott lässt walten gesungen also
sie hat ihren glauben nicht verloren ich
kann mir das auch nicht verstehen
vorstellen was aber ganz kurz ich glaube
auch nicht dass ich mir etwas vorstellen
könnte seit ich mutter bin ist das
schlimmste ist kannst du wahrscheinlich
nachvollziehen was mir passieren könnte
ist meiner tochter was passiert und dann
selbst dann werde ich noch hoffen dass
mich etwas trägt ich weiß es nicht
frau käßmann vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch sehr gerne ja jetzt
gleich geht es weiter mit der
reformation wir zeigen eine
dokumentation und ein gespräch über den
skandal auf vielen ursula ein film über
die zürcher reformation der vor 30
jahren die gemüter massiv erregte wenn
sie also der bilder nicht mögen sollten
sie in der nächsten halben stunde an
zwei oder drei stellen kurz wegschauen
doch verpassten sollten sie diese
sternstunde erfahrung und im november
stoßen wir dann so richtigen abgründige
und dunkle irgendwann vor wir zeigen am
samstagabend dem 25 november und 23 uhr
die erste sternstunde der nacht auf sf
zwei eine zweistündige sondersendung zum
thema pornografie aufzeichnung werden
wir das ganze am montag dem 20 november
im zürcher kaufleuten und zwar mit
publikum kommen sie aus und diskutieren
sie mit
anmelden können sie sich jetzt auf
unserer sendung seite nun wünsche ich
ihnen aber erst einmal einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]